in the 1960s in the United States with the
passing of the Civil Rights Act.
We saw what many consider to be sort of the
official end of the absolute most explicit
and formal types of government racism.
When we ended mandated segregation, we outlawed
many other types of racial discrimination.
But since then, and really to this day, black
and Hispanic Americans continue to suffer
from a variety of social and economic inequities
with regard to wealth, education, health outcomes,
cycles of crime and incarceration.
The list is a mile long.
When we're talking about socioeconomic adversities
that disproportionately impact populations
of color over the past 50 or 60 years.
In the time since the civil rights movement,
we've seen many racial equality movements
try to illuminate and put a spotlight on and
address these problems.
And these movements tend to acknowledge that
these problems are the ripple effects of historical
institutional racism, like slavery and Jim
Crow.
And these movements have pushed for solutions
that are designed to help these groups in
particular as remedies for problems that impact
them disproportionately.
This has taken the form of affirmative action
scholarships for minority students, bussing
to integrate schools, federal financial support
for historically black colleges, government
programs that help minority businesses.
These are all forms of action that solve or
try to solve race based problems in the United
States.
Over the past half century, what we've also
seen consistently in parallel is pushback
against these racial equality initiatives.
Here are a few clips of some popular conservatives
making comments which I believe accurately
sum up, sum up the prevailing right wing narrative
on systemic racism with regard to socioeconomics.
One could certainly say during the Jim Crow
era when when, you know, African-Americans
couldn't vote, that systemic racism.
You have to look things in the system that
are contributing to racism.
Is systemic racism still a reality today?
It is not a real reality.
It is the opposite of reality.
It's all an illusion.
You can point to me, to the law or the practice
that's in place that makes that somehow keeps
me out.
If there's two people that are working the
exact same and putting out the scene as early
as a month after, you're going to tell me
that as a black person, I can't get ahead.
It doesn't exist.
There are lots of rich black people in America,
and I know lots of poor white people in America.
So what is it?
Because black people in the United States
are disproportionately poorer than white people
in the United States?
It's actually yeah, it's ignoring the real
problem, which is how do we get poor people
to be richer?
Systemic racism does not exist.
There are no laws in America.
Meaning the system doesn't mean racism doesn't
exist.
Racism exists.
There are people who are racist.
And you should do everything you can to show
them that their ideas are wrong and that you
should not be judging someone based on their
race, of course.
But the idea that there is systemic racism,
meaning that there are laws in place that
treat black people differently or Asian people
differently or white people differently simply
doesn't exist.
Treat you if you can get an economy that is
as free as possible, you will have more and
more people, regardless of the color of their
skin, being able to partake in an economy.
So those comments cover a bunch of the predominant
views from the right on systemic racism.
Those were clips of three of the most popular
right wing online broadcasters.
So the first thing I want to point out is
they are defining systemic racism so narrowly
that it would only refer to racism by the
government and only the most explicit and
official forms of government racism like Jim
Crow, for example.
And that's how they're able to say that systemic
racism doesn't exist.
If someone's constantly asserting something
that everyone already accepts is true, such
as slavery and Jim Crow no longer exist, it's
likely that they're either accidentally or
purposefully misunderstanding what they are
trying to argue against.
That's what's happening here.
I've never encountered someone who asserts
that systemic racism is a problem today while
defining racism in such a narrow way.
People usually use the term systemic racism
to denote any type of racial biases, formal
or informal biased system, or someone acting
on behalf of a system which could take the
form of racial bias by police officers or
by a law enforcement system.
Racial bias by people hiring at a company.
Racial bias in education like a standardized
test that puts certain racial groups at a
disadvantage.
It doesn't even necessarily have to be racism
by an individual.
Importantly, it could just be a system doing
something that in practice disadvantages members
of a certain group on the basis of their race.
And I think that the concept requiring a little
bit of nuance is exactly why some people get
confused.
Some people get defensive about the word racism
being involved.
So maybe we can have a separate conversation
about finding a better term, which is fine.
But that's what people mean when they say
there is active systemic racism present in
the year 2020.
So I think a lot of conservatives are confused
about the definition.
If they act as though it's synonymous only
with slavery and Jim Crow or some of them
are straw manning in bad faith to avoid actually
engaging with the reality on the ground.
But the conservatives I played in the clips,
what they also seem to be saying is that systemic
racism as someone like me would define it
doesn't exist.
Their sentiment is slavery and Jim Crow are
over.
Black people no longer face any types of disadvantages.
There are no systemic biases against black
people.
There are no lingering effects from historical
institutional inequality, unfairness that
still leave the deck stacked against minority
individuals.
Black and white people on average have identical
opportunity to succeed, they would assert.
The other thing they seem to be saying is
that because they don't believe those racial
biases exist, we shouldn't be looking at minority
poverty through the lens of race in order
to solve solve it with racial social justice
action.
They say we should instead look at black poverty,
for example, as an arbitrary piece of poverty
as a whole.
And we should try to solve black poverty merely
by fixing poverty as a whole.
And in addition to saying that racial solutions
to, for example, black or Hispanic poverty
are unnecessary.
Often they will add that those racial solutions
dismiss, ignore or be little white poverty,
and they discount the personal responsibility
of nonwhite individuals to improve their.
Own lives, but it's not surprising that that's
the direction conservatives would go, because
each of those pieces fits beautifully into
the conservative media narratives that we've
been following.
For example, racial inequality is generally
overblown.
Identity politics is bad.
Government intervention is the wrong way to
fix anything.
Capitalism and meritocracy ultimately are
the answers to everything.
Will conservatives like these are not realizing
is that there are social and economic problems
today in the United States that affect minorities
in specific ways.
Black folks as a group do have certain types
of particular disadvantages.
And to admit that is a reality doesn't mean
that you're deriding the poverty of other
races or in general.
And it doesn't mean you're devaluing anybody's
individual responsibility.
It doesn't mean that there aren't things we
can also be doing generally to help everybody
in a situation of hardship, regardless of
race.
Of course, we want to be thinking about those
solutions, too.
And I talk about those solutions every day.
I might even agree with somebody like Ben
Shapiro when he says that the mere existence
of a black white poverty gap alone is not
necessarily a justification for using race
as the context to fix black poverty.
The fact that black folks are impoverished
at a higher rate than white people by itself
might not justify racial solutions as opposed
to solutions that improve the lives of all
groups.
But what these people on the right seem never
to recognize is that certain opportunity gaps
also still exist.
Not only do black folks in many respects have
worse outcomes, on average, black folks also
have diminished opportunity to improve those
outcomes compared to white people on average,
on average.
That's what these conservatives are missing.
And it's the reason why it is actually useful
to explore certain solutions that are tailored
towards certain particular racial inequalities.
In some ways, black and white poverty can
be different.
There are many metrics that illustrate gaps
between a black person and a white person
of the same income.
There was a groundbreaking study by Stanford
and Harvard researchers from 2018, which combines
census data on race with IRS tax returns,
allowing them to compare the income of parents
with the income of their grown children over
the span of 1989 to 2015 for the purpose of
tracking intergenerational mobility, which
is the degree to which children economically
surpass their parents or fall behind.
And what they found is that downward mobility
occurs at a much higher rate among black Americans
than among white Americans.
When you compare black and white people with
similar incomes.
This was true even among the children of higher
income parents of both races.
Children of white parents in the top fifth
of the income distribution have a 41 percent
chance of staying at that income level.
Children of black parents in that highest
income level only have an 18 percent chance
of staying at that income level.
So regardless of how much money your parents
make, if you are black, you are less likely
to achieve the economic status of your parents
or higher.
Sadly, I can already imagine some people are
going to butt in with, oh, well, maybe it
has something to do with intelligence or single
parenthood or something like that.
The study found that the black white mobility
gap is entirely driven by black and white
males.
There was very little gap between black and
white females, which would rule out genetic
factors between races as an explanation.
If that's your sort of thing to look at, the
study also looked at family structure and
it found that the huge gap is there, regardless
of whether children came from one or two parent
homes, which debunks the conservative idea
that lower marriage rates are responsible.
But a factor that does tend to powerfully
predict economic mobility is the average income
of the neighborhood in which a child was raised.
A study by Harvard economists published in
2015 showed overwhelming evidence for this.
The researchers looked at 16 years of tax
records to track pairs of children and parents,
and they found that the affluence of a child's
neighborhood is the single best predictor
of their long term upward mobility.
The amount of money in an area where a child
grows up is strongly correlated with that
child's ability to achieve more socioeconomic
success than their parents.
A study was published in 2015 by the American
Academy of Political and Social Science, conducted
by researchers at Stanford.
By looking at census data which found that
among black and white families with similar
incomes, white families are much more likely
to live in neighborhoods with higher average
incomes.
And of course, this means.
That the white family is more likely to have
access to better schools, better childcare,
better parks, better transportation options.
The list of advantages in a high income neighborhood
relative to a low income neighborhood is a
very, very long list.
And between a black and white family of similar
income, the difference between the average
incomes of their neighborhoods is not small.
It's huge.
So to put all of this together, we have the
mobility gap between black and white people
of similar incomes.
The mobility of anyone, regardless of race,
tends to be predicted by the average income
of the neighborhood where they grew up.
And we see that a black family with the same
income as a white family is more likely to
live in a poor neighborhood.
And that's because black people tend to live
near other black people and black people have
lower incomes than white people on average.
And of course, that is what we call racial
housing segregation, the geographic separation
of races.
And it is a racial issue.
So we've demonstrated one of many examples
of a social problem in 2020, which can be
usefully analyzed in terms of race.
And it warrants racial justice action.
The problem is that black folks have less
upward mobility than white folks.
The cause of the problem is racial housing
segregation.
And the solution would be integrating housing
to a greater degree.
There are so many other examples of social
problems today that demand racial justice
solutions in education, health care, the justice
system.
I'd have nowhere near enough time in this
video to go into each and every one of them.
So let's flesh out this example.
We're dealing with housing segregation.
Before we start talking about solutions to
segregation, we should contemplate how the
housing segregation that exists today came
to be.
A lot of people think that people of the same
races ended up living in the same areas accidentally
or as a result of personal choice.
But actually, most of today's racial segregation
in every city across America results from
explicitly racist government policies.
Throughout the late 19th and early 20th century,
many American cities passed zoning ordinances
prohibiting black people from moving onto
a block that was majority white.
Starting in 1934, the federal government gave
white people better access to affordable mortgages
while designating black neighborhoods in cities
across America as zones where banks should
not offer mortgages.
This was known as redlining, which encouraged
white people to move to homogenously white
suburbs.
And it trapped black people in decaying neighborhoods.
Also, in the 1930s, the Public Works Administration
built tens of thousands of public housing
complexes all over the country, all of which
had a designation for which racial group was
allowed to live there.
And almost all of them were either all white
or all black.
And much of the racial segregation that it
caused is still present today.
There are plenty of other instances of government
mandating racial housing segregation.
Deliberate, codified government racism is
what gave us almost all of the housing segregation
we see today.
And now white people and black people are
more segregated from one another than white
people are segregated from Asian or Hispanic
people as examples and more so than poor and
nonpoor, people are segregated from one another.
And black white segregation puts a hugely
unfair burden on black people.
It has much worse effects for a black family
living in a black neighborhood who have the
same income and education as a white family
living in a white neighborhood.
The average middle class black family lives
in a neighborhood with a higher poverty rate
than the average low income white person.
Segregation also prevents home values from
appreciating in black neighborhoods because
of white folks reluctance to buy a home in
a black neighborhood.
Even when all other attributes of homes and
neighborhoods are equal, which, by the way,
is an example of systemic racism happening
actively in the year 2020, and it's a type
of systemic racism with a huge impact on black
wealth.
Since someone's home is often their largest
financial asset.
So the crucial thing here is that higher poverty
rates in the neighborhood means lower quality
resources for everyone who lives there.
Segregation is the biggest barrier between
black people in higher income wealth.
Better education, health care, employment
opportunities and so on.
One might even be able to say that today the
government's refusal to integrate housing
more effectively to fix the problems that
government created originally could itself
be another example of ongoing systemic racism
in 2020.
The government not doing something is just
as much a policy decision as the government
doing something.
Sure, someone like Ben Shapiro can sit back
and say, yeah, okay, whatever happened in
the.
Passed with racism and segregation was bad.
But now that the government has stopped actively
mandating segregation, we can just wipe the
slate clean.
We can just blame individual black people
for being poor.
But that would be a complete misunderstanding
of the forces that created these problems
and the forces that would be necessary to
fix them.
Government has a ton of power, obviously,
and it used this power to segregate for a
long time.
That same amount of power would be required
to undo it.
This is where we get to the distinction between
desegregation and integration.
Desegregation is when a government stops separating
people.
Integration is the process of un separating
those same people, which has not happened.
So we're currently stuck in a state of segregation,
essentially in a way.
The Civil Rights Act did not accomplish as
much as conservatives seem to think it did.
It didn't hit the reset button on racial inequality.
Racial groups in the United States are not
on a level playing field.
So what can government do to counteract segregation
as a way to give black people more economic
opportunity?
Well, to start with, we could reinstitute
the Obama era policy of requiring localities
that receive federal money for housing to
identify and try to remedy housing practices
that promote racial bias.
The policy that was suspended by the Trump
administration, which Donald Trump completely
blew out of proportion in terms of what it
did.
And Donald Trump has made clear that he has
no interest in dealing with that issue and
in fact, in his personal past has a history
of racial housing discrimination.
Commenting on his elimination of this anti-racist
policy, Trump actually tweeted, I am happy
to inform all of the people living in their
suburban lifestyle dream that you will no
longer be bothered or financially hurt by
having low income housing built in your neighborhood.
Enjoy.
That's another example of institutional racism
in 2020.
If I've ever seen one.
Another step we could take to counter segregation
by reducing housing discrimination is to increase
the use of fair housing testers who are individuals
who pose as potential buyers and renters to
gather information on possible instances of
illegal racial housing discrimination because
this discrimination tends to push black people
out of white areas.
Tests like these have been funded by the Department
of Housing and Urban Development, and they've
uncovered a staggering amount of racial discrimination.
For example, they did a test in Chicago in
2018 and identified racial discrimination
at twenty seven percent of the time.
There's some more current systemic racism
as an example for you.
Nevertheless, HUD does not fund these tests
anywhere near the level that matches how pervasive
and destructive we observe this problem to
be.
We have to be better about enforcing anti
housing discrimination laws that are already
on the books.
Government could also be bolstering inclusionary
zoning policies, which require homebuilders
to make sure that portions of new housing
units are affordable to low and moderate income
people to eliminate the financial barriers
that often end up keeping poor black families
from finding an affordable home in a good
neighborhood.
We could also be using more federal housing
subsidies to help lower income black families
move into better neighborhoods.
The low income housing tax credit could be
used to develop subsidized rental housing
in nonpoor neighborhoods.
There is great new research that illustrates
that what we have been doing with this has
had huge payoffs, especially for the kids
of low income families.
There are many other strategies we could be
using to disperse black families so that lower
income households aren't so concentrated.
New policies that can be implemented and through
better funding and enforcement of initiatives
that already exist could be significantly
beneficial.
But I wanted to explore just racial housing
segregation as an example to illustrate some
points about systemic racism and how much
can be done about it.
It's a topic that is always relevant and worthy
of a deep dove, but especially right now with
everything going on with Black Lives Matter,
the discussions around race that are happening
over the past few months while they've had
the country's attention, black folks in the
U.S. and allies of all kinds have been trying
to shed light on a number of really important
problems in the country.
Things that this country has to start dealing
with, it's way overdue.
But I'm seeing some people actually confused
about what are even the starting points for
these conversations.
The reality is racism can take many different
forms.
Some people just have an overly simplistic
conception of what racism is.
People start talking about systemic racism.
Conservatives respond with I have no idea
what you're talking about.
We have no more slavery.
Jim Crow is over.
We ended that a long time ago.
So racial injustice no longer exists.
That perspective misunderstands.
Deliberately or accidentally.
What systemic racism is.
And it ignores the fact that systemic racism
exists and is just another form of racism.
We also have to refute the common conservative
notion that black hardships can only be productively
discussed in the context of hardship or poverty
in general.
Instead of acknowledging additional racial
components that are often involved, there
are some issues that are more accurately understood
when you take into account racial injustices
that may be at play.
So that you can solve them with specially
catered solutions.